[Music]
now society has idea of people with
disabilities that you're not capable you
can't do for yourself you need people to
do things for you
and and that's not true boxing for us
it's like a break from a lot of the
pressures that we deal with in our lives
everything and I provide that breathing
man and I enjoyed every bit of the
passion that lasts a smile
people really enjoy themselves and a lot
of times people need to let loose
you know you all get in that dark place
we all deal with the ugly side of
disabilities but just hitting up the
focus mitts while hitting the bag may be
a great release or some people stop it
or let's go to adaptive boxing but
trying to bring the community together
and my goal is to help better lives to
boxing
[Music]
growing up in the Bronx you know we have
the whole world and one borough there's
a lot of culture history it's rich at
the same time it's a dark place when I
was 19
I'm 64 I was about ready to enlist into
Marines that's what I wanted to do
something to be proud of and a way to
escape my environment and you know I'm
coming home from the store my night
[Music]
Austrade both you know wasn't a my
weight just pretty [ __ ] off a pole and
that's it doctors tell me what I liked
meeting never walk again I thought life
is open you know if I can't do for
myself what benefit I am to anybody else
or to society so I attended suicide
didn't work of course I knew that I had
to be better and that was the turning
point for me so I started taking a
boxing boxing is basically a way to
climb out some scene is violent but some
of us see it as a way to utilize that
spirit we have inside of us something
happens where you get comfortable with
the hits you get comfortable with
throwing punches and it's almost like a
dance between you and that person
this is study about smart and learning
and it's fun as exciting it's beautiful
things and I want to show that to other
people so I started my own adaptive
boxing camp here in New York I'll put
you right on you well she gonna do she
gonna do it feels great because it's
something I believed in and I presented
it for people and they accepted it open
arms all right guys so we're gonna do
some adaptive boxing we're gonna start
with some shadow boxing some stretching
get all heart pumping things like that
have a good experience okay pretty soon
I realized that it wasn't just a boxing
it was the actual relationships that I
built I go to bed excited for the next
day I want to have a group session you
know and we become you share this
experience of of laughs and jokes and
work and sweat you start the left left
right there are many of us that left are
coming together in our small community
and this changes the narrative of how
they think of themselves how they see
life how to interact with people and how
the world sees knows some people grew up
in the wheelchairs and this is a sport
that they've always seen so I give that
to him and this is what they're looking
for like I said some of us still want to
kick ass it's a whole new fighting
method we're moving around you know
there's no stabilizers so your punches
will move your chair hands up chin down
so he has to get used to and you're
comfortable with his chair moving
getting the best position in the ring
not getting hit dealing damage and I'm
receiving it this is bigger than just
boxing ring I've realized that this is
gonna impact people in so many aspects
osot out corners so Corey what's gonna
happen is right
you're throwing punches Tyrell was
trying to get out of it without getting
hit
keep a Manticore you keep a minute it's
Cory throw the jab what are you supposed
to do wrong that's what you want all
right
[Music]
in the way I'm very from this happened
weeks I don't know where I was headed
I don't know if I were to survive the
tour let alone two three four toys to do
I don't know but this is the car that I
have and this is what I have to work
with and I affect many in a positive way
and that's a great existence
I could look myself in the mirror and
I'm happy my spirit is happy my heart is
happy I'm following my passion for now
I'm using every outlet as possible to
get this message out and to break it
away
[Music]
alright done take a little breather
[Music]